and welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winners win we have the whole gang here
- Ari Shaffir little poor little off for
my dead homie right there
have we heard from him has anyone ever
heard from Tyson I saw there's a number
above today I saw him running a marathon
supposedly there's a picture of him
running a marathon at some point never
put that up that was good oh please tell
me he's a runner now secretly do you
love running hey Oh breaking news about
Ari I just saw recently put on 15 pounds
and is trying to take it off Oh leave it
dude I'm tired of seeing those two bones
you have as a manorexia back I saw him
put up a thing it's like hey I want to
shave off 15 pounds I'm getting a little
I love when he like thinks he's fat and
he's so obsessed with food look at that
that check that's right that's when he
was thin because like he's so probably
finish my first boston marathon by
blowing passes dumb [ __ ] that post of
the day who posted that for us really
that's what we talk about when we're not
look up these new fiance okay the best
stuff is always before the podcast we
should do a pre podcast podcast yeah
randoms Dennis O'Neil got me into this
nightmare all Russian chick my friend
Porsche I got me into this 90-day fiance
show he's all they're not all Russian
she is and she's a lot of Thai lot of
she Rushville are you awful
she'd be rates if she just here for a
green card and tells him she's here for
like she goes I don't love you I don't
like you know by herself and she'll say
this is not expensive enough yes he just
staying with her for the show he just
thinks she's no he's like crazy yeah
he's like look at her she's so beautiful
I'll never get that good and then she
puts up a so much it I think it's like a
fetish for him though
but anyway be berated yeah like he likes
me she just says getting a green card
then she's just gonna jam no she's gonna
milk him Drive
he's a sugar daddy to her they were
looking for houses boys he wanted this
crate we business he's in jail now he's
in jail he's in jail and she's like a
bodybuilder we need a body but anyway
that's power they got me the show we
were talking about it before this show
could have been called fat white chicks
and brown people from around the world
because there's a lot of that going on
in this show I wanna call fat white
chicks yeah no no I'm saying it's always
like a Puerto Rican fat chick who's like
I never been in love before never till I
met Jose on a vacation so much and he's
like some shredder in Puerto Rico so
their day Danielle and Mohamed he's
trying to get a green card straight up
right when he got the green card laughs
pretty much like hysterically crying for
to love me he says her [ __ ] smiled on
the TV
that's the war he's the one where this
guy ever to live yeah and it's always
old rich white guys hate [ __ ]
oh he's a complete scumbag she's 19 he's
just very controlling he married someone
else that he's the biggest [ __ ] ever
from that country has three kids with
her and then she bails so he's just down
there that's another one on the bottom
line yeah that's the best couple of dick
there's green card oh absolutely would
you would you why he looks like a Wayans
brother
I'll show you though this one is just
absolutely called her sister-in-law
contest trick-ass [ __ ] ass how do you
remember that me and Jess they let
around the house she's from Colombia she
meets this guy who does like oil work on
the oil rigs he's gay let's get Johnny
won come on Johnny I'd love to see that
episode what country would you be
fishing in Johnny where if you're gonna
get a 90-day fiance what country would
you with be throwing your hook in to
pull one up pull one over maybe like
Brazil
okay I see where you been I think I said
they don't really need green cards in
Brazil
it's a good country I mean nobody's
friendly I don't know man
no everybody wants to come here now
who's to chick up there who's that
which one in the red zone this is all
Powell she's the hottest one in my
opinion and do they know what they're
getting oh yeah oh yeah you know they're
not ordering them they always meet in
their country like I'm on vacation in
you know the Bahamas and I meet some
chick and then they stay in touch on
skype and [ __ ] and then and it's called
90-day fiance because they get a visa to
come for 90 days to make sure that their
so that when they land here they have 90
days to get married or they have to go
back to their country my father and so
they've already known each other and
they're all but it's always a shame
lasted not many I get too excited and I
google ahead because they're just such
disasters oh my god I'm like who is that
baby what about you Sam what country are
you fishing in dude that's a great
question right I'm gonna go Costa Rica's
pretty hot right okay can you go to the
pop our ranked ajiz there so new power
ranks to Latin chicks rushing chicks are
hot but they're not know you'll back up
a new craze that's hub with [ __ ] ice
in and your kidneys gone Iceland's
pretty hot but I'm still burning I was
thinking somewhere over there like
Brazil's but we did
Sweden's hot there's a lot of numbers in
Sweden look look here look up number one
countries for a green card ass okay
google something Sam you would
absolutely be hilarious also for the
typos yeah number one selling doesn't
work I'm sorry oh dude you suck for
green cards no rate rate hottest group
what countries have the hottest girls
yeah yeah I wanna see a list cuz I'm
gonna think about mine cuz three is
number one oh yeah Brazil that was my
vote so job have a language barrier
though Brazil oh yeah oh boy Australia
to Austria number two but yeah I'm out
I'm out yeah
I've watched too many episodes of that
90 day Brad show fiance - no you ain't
[ __ ] with these Russian [ __ ] every
one of them even the guy rushing was an
[ __ ] lavake yeah who was the guy
Russian you might not know that season
oh yeah what about like Czech Republic
or Switzerland Sam said Switzerland yeah
a bidet that's a nice country you have
to be a [ __ ] country so it wants to get
green yeah
can I count Texas as a country Venezuela
what is that one I'm out I'm out I'm
Venezuela yeah because Colombia
yeah Colombia yeah she's cute as [ __ ]
yeah oh boy so you guys like Latin women
the most well that's all I like it put
Israeli chick Ukraine put it Israeli
China they don't need yeah but they're
hot - Ukraine I don't trust either
I'm sorry Ukraine you guys also seems
like you don't trust it Ukrainian now
they seem real shanky they do they do
they they're basically Russians I love
it their cranium there we go oh yeah go
back to your [ __ ] Latin check please
don't make a list of the top 10 highest
women Ukraine sign holy America Lebanon
I never thought about Lebanon and I'm
not gonna anymore [ __ ] you Lebanon
Angola Angola get and get out of here
that's what it is Israeli USA is coming
in at 10:00 okay oh [ __ ] out of here
we're number one uh man I might go
Israeli based on that tonight I really
might cuz they're not gonna get my chief
edition Lebanese women what else is
there and they're Christian too right so
you want to worry about all the other
[ __ ] I don't care about all the other
[ __ ] look up police look at the police
force in Lebanon oh look at that yeah
what are the Girl Scouts was that for no
lisboa pornos that a girl
ban Lebanon mayor house police went
that's a police cover band they're a
police cover band on the left looks 13
Thank You crime
everyone's got tits and that's a good
thing
Hey weather look up some more countries
I'm enjoying this fuss for where I got a
lot women seems good we've talked enough
sports forever even though we're gonna
talk about the greatest comeback in NBA
playoff history
all rights too busy packing um I'm gonna
go do dirty water moving boy did you see
his post on Instagram yeah he's giving
away always [ __ ]
yeah everybody if anybody's in New York
damn it a fire sale poise serum I mean
anything you want for the low price of
zero dollars and 31 points
I got kitchenware I got a couch where is
he moving to i got a new place grill
with propane 31 points so yeah go to
Artie's Instagram if you live in the
Newark area especially if you are young
comics oh yeah something for comics but
if you're a comic in the New York City
area
Brazil Brazil goddamn good go to artis
Instagram and cut post back he put his
actual address up and he's given away a
lot of his stuff for the price of free
and you've seen most of it on the show
yeah most of it [ __ ] or pissed on come
Profis brazil's brought by a brazil's up
there it's something had about a girl
with a whistle in her mouth are you guys
shocked are you settling down and
letting a woman decorate an apartment
and everything i would do it i just
don't have time sure that means he says
i don't want any of my stuff and he's
letting her be domestic philippines no
yeah they annoy me
Bulgaria's how are you yeah
you're not getting a Dutch one in
assignments yeah mmm
Egypt ah
France yeah but they don't want they'll
need visas there Argentina there I do
like a whole bit on a horse
Amish Argentinians yeah South Korea no
give me North Korea South Korea doesn't
need us
yeah no South Korea need us there are
some high Indian chicks there are some
papa john's south korean babies when
they're born there one they have a way
of counting and some babies they're born
at the end of the year when the year
turns over there too but their newborns
isn't that crazy
yeah it's called [ __ ] yeah it's
stupid and that's why the country so
you're like two years older Venezuela
that's the best you got oh that guy's
Down syndrome I'm not picking these
photos
Johnny pic pic these photos better
Brazil okay okay it was good Ukraine
we've I said they're Shady Columbia
she's been hot for like how many decades
that Catherine zeta-jones hot forever
this chick I know not how she's eighty
sweetie
interesting I'm good I'm going Sweden I
remember when I'm going go I see I went
to Sweden Iceland but when he went and
he's like they're so hot they make me
look like a wench that cleans bath and
then you were like talking about a hot
sweet I'm going Sweden final answer
90-day fiance keeps coming to Sweden I'm
going the country of Chad you're going
knock [ __ ] I don't like this I like
blondie I like it you know why cuz they
have pink [ __ ] blonde hair yes see
that yeah god damn Iceland yeah and they
don't know [ __ ] either you could treat
you swindle them any which way you want
and by which I'm down for for me alright
it's been a great podcast we'll see you
guys soon
31 points dude 30 as anyone could talk
about this we handily still going off on
chicks ever we talked enough sports for
the rest of our lives let's talk about
how girls let's talk about hot ladies
let's talk about the greatest comeback
Clippers for an hour
did you watch it at all no I thought you
were Clippers man not once everybody
left and then once JJ left I hate to it
I was missing him last night got rid of
all the dead weight did ya look at that
lovely way well the good news I love it
I love everybody I think it's one of the
most underrated players outside of the
Clippers organization you know I mean 25
I mean like look at that dude your bench
guy goes for 36 shame it was huge too
not just that shot he gave a mop man I
cannot believe they gave that guy up
look at his plus/minus he has the best
plus minus one team me what's been
playing great defense plus 15 Oh kid
gorgeous not that great but that's fine
he's gonna be great though oh yes really
yeah and then marques Harrell is killing
everybody 25 and 10
god damn it was fun to watch they just
started hitting shots and and going the
statement when it's just frozen cold and
the numbers Playboy because is done for
the season are they yeah they say they
said he I believe I heard he has a torn
quadric
oh my god I feel bad for him yeah yeah
what is he going four-wheeling for and
that should be a rarity and will
determine the length of recovery how
long it could be out it's unclear if he
will need surgery but he's out or how
long he could be out not bad but heard
this morning I'm not afraid of bomb
League sources told ESPN on Monday night
that there was evidence that the injury
was considered season-ending but
don't have okay III had heard that how
long would he be out for season ending I
mean but but is it like a year injury is
it like I don't think it during the port
God all that matters is all the playoffs
he'll still get a ring if they win
cousins missed almost a full year I mean
it Dowell can come out the star I'll
know ma'am but they don't have as much
firepower Durant Durant fella no it
helped yeah I mean early they're getting
all the call three minutes later three
minutes
Oh a lot of green had a hell of a flop -
you see that one on the top of the key
oh he didn't even touch him on that play
how great is Patrick Beverley yeah I saw
that ball from that was Ellis big - that
was huge yeah turn him oh man he's a nut
job you got to pay him yeah he's defense
I think every NBA team needs like a
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] crazy people like
when Rodman was on the balls you know
you need a [ __ ] I'm looking for that
every team needs their Chad sumac okay
I'm looking for the game sets it was
like 99.9% box score no this thing right
here win probability look at this dude
only when you need the wind and the
Miller third quarters 99.9% that the
Clippers are gonna lose today we're
gonna lose look at that
so that's like oh yeah unbelievable - so
improbable 1/10 of a percent likely now
you come back to LA Thursday I'm going I
bought ticket did you yep I'm going with
Tommy God 200
are you in the box though yeah we're up
agree I'm just excited to be there dude
I'm just excited but to be in lucky box
is great it's a little far away but I
still like to sit there I enjoy it which
side is his box wound he has been he has
me to go last time that side what do you
mean the other side but I mean are you
under a more Center quarter more under a
bucket you're kind of more Center cards
oh that's great it's great dude I'm
excited man these playoffs have been
great
can we agree on that I mean it's early I
mean the first game so far there's a lot
of upsets you know what really
that happens odds it's kind of crazy
because guess who isn't in the playoffs
and there re more exciting
your good friend LeBron James I don't
miss him I don't miss him at all I have
I mean we still got to hear about the
Clippers 1-1 against the defending
champions and honestly you still hear
more about the Lakers out here in a life
airs on the notional on the news all
sports talk radio they're not even in
the playoffs wrong cuz they didn't have
a name
they didn't have a coach are you why are
we talking about him are you wishing you
putting a bet on her the one now the
climbers were the ones win to see I did
but I [ __ ] it up believe me it's not
the same odds anyways moving right along
but what it were the I went on bet Dias
I bet these aside for all your bet needs
I went to bet TSI I used the promo code
punch 25 and guess what you made the
wrong bet here's a fun gambling slurry
Game of Thrones went live early on
DirecTV and bookies who had bets for the
first episode took a bath apparently
that's according to TMZ who's a lot of
people made a lot of prop bets and they
already knew before it tactically aired
like who's gonna speak first on the show
everything yeah and you could do it at
bat Diaz I look Easley's big on Game of
Thrones after DirecTV the leaks premiere
four hours early
that's betting for people like me that
don't watch sports they give me exactly
I only care about TV shows yeah yep see
you don't even know how do they do their
pump rules and that would be great
1990 de vionnet mom and Katie are gonna
have a fight there's an exit eeeh that's
gonna get pushed out of flight of stairs
at the Rain Man of fan of reality TV
bets why are you uh punch I'm trying to
see what the UH it's punch-drunk sports
go there everything's cooking could have
won money I'm I could have won money on
tiger I guess jag lens all these unders
came they did all the unders except for
what I think no he's just said the first
game right bet the first round he said
they all came under yeah somebody else
hit me up on on Twitter and said they
took our advice on like three different
bats and prop them
I bet GSI and album came through they
made like 800 bucks you're welcome
you're welcome all of you see we're not
always wrong we're not always wrong
we're usually right all the time in life
very rarely do we [ __ ] up yeah-ha
greatest already hit us up and said that
a right when the Clippers series started
if you went on Bette DSi and put $100
down pays 10 grand
now the odds are a little bit different
since we got in that ass last night but
had you had the foresight to think about
that that's nothing 200 hundred bucks
and and 25 of its three told you do it I
put I put 20 on it so what do you have
you get her in the one that you said no
idea all you would have to do is put in
like $35 roughly because 25 of it is
free if you use the code punch 25 right
and then they double whatever you put in
up to 500 bucks so you put in 500 bucks
now you have a thousand bucks so put in
the minimum amount just get in there Pat
the SI user code punch 25 throw in 30
bucks and throw it all on the Clippers
because it pays great and it's not
probably not gonna happen I think it
well though I don't know I don't I don't
think about I hope it will I all you got
to do is get man Majan if they win both
there are 3-1 if they went both games in
LA dude and then it's 3-1 going back to
sam and tolki that's big firepower
mentally to mentally mentally clay clay
that's a pretty good trio we have
literally on trio draymond green
Gallinari mop Martez or whatever his
name is I tell you we don't have the
[ __ ] firepower of JJ read it oh I'm
so happy he's not on our team then we
also afraid of them dude I'm not afraid
of them we have some good guys coming
off the bench take any shots
Lou Williams he's your best player Lou
Williams I'm concerned Gallinari
montrezl harrell shaman I mean
oh dude it's a deep squad it's a deep
squad one thing that I would say Shaun
Livingston would still be maybe I was
just gonna say that
yeah I really was cuz I loved it with
him when we drafted him I loved him okay
temples TC Williams Chandler did he get
any points only two green greens good
too man what happened to Chandler man
he's just old how many points did how
many points did draymond Green have 14
yeah dude our creation was great and one
I insist
what incredible flop how many sister our
green house I'll be comparing Green Zone
yeah we got green one is this yeah buddy
seven rebounds you're welcome
I'll see how many rebounds frame on him
that's bad for him actually he should is
bad dude and patch Beverly's in their
heads
he's only 31 Wilson Chandler he's fell
off yeah he fell off cuz he's just got
saggy diaper Dan that was great dude so
much good stuff it was great and it was
one of those real like it's [ __ ] 30
it kind of just zone out in your head
and slowly slowly volatile and then when
it was like [ __ ] maybe even 11 Wow 12
I'm like holy [ __ ] right around right
guys see all right that's why I got like
12 I think when Bella ball from curry
and then they had it to like five and
three and I'm like dude there's four
minutes left and this is a three point
game there's a five point game the crowd
didn't know what to do to and boogie was
done already by then but then like three
minutes left or so Durant fouls out and
it's a forty three point game with
Durant fouled out and I'm like this is a
totally different three minutes you know
they're down two starters and one of
them is their clutch scorer yeah don't
you think the next game is like the most
important is series though because if
some sound blows them out yeah then it's
everything's back the game you're going
to I believe is me up the pivot game
yeah of the series if the Clippers win
even if they keep it really close I
think then it kind of changes things or
if there's like a major like a
major catastrophe like I'm great we win
this week we win both games we win the
first on Thursday I'm calling it
you bet no I do not $20 I mean either
the club I'll give me points what about
DSi yeah go on back to us I use the
promo code puncturing five you put you
put money on the series you were just
saying yeah and but you took you took a
bet that wasn't what you thought it was
what you do I think you just think it
the same way to do it yeah but you my
question is the bet that you made was
Clippers are gonna win the series right
okay what'd you throw on that okay I
mean it's still that still had to pay
good 20 yards in that pies I should be
like 500 said a hundred was ten thousand
on my twenty still has to be good yeah
so yeah yes yeah you're playing it tell
me to do these bets I would have put a
hundred and to make ten thousand you are
a [ __ ] gambling addicted mother you
have baby Larry oh happy birthday to
baby Larry everybody baby Larry turned
one on Saturday right a lot of tweets
and I was like how do people know and
like well people really listen and then
I realize you did a shout out good thank
you
honestly every time people comment like
Oh Dave's getting so big I really laughs
so I really do what it what it uh
what did you guys do for a little baby
Rick yeah a party we had a party
Saturday at my mom's house and all
Jeff's family flew out Oh families all
met oh that's nice they've been here a
week just family they left this morning
we've got a big present a big like a big
almost like a game of Thrones class
white trash and Jews they were more
nervous to me my family who like you
said is white trash like my family like
you why your family's so nice oh yeah oh
yeah anybody anybody yeah exactly
exactly yeah yeah no I'm just adds like
did we pass the test I'm like yeah you
have to kill the baby what my dad's ever
say like we don't like those like fancy
nice people like what
means what well they're all from so the
party was in Monroe you know that this
meeting of the families it was Boston
meeting what Bakersfield were you from
Monrovia just close to here
kind of like Pasadena yeah in between
Pasadena in Azusa what's in Monrovia
anything other than houses other than
like suburban houses know a lot of math
it's like a casino there you know it's
like nice it's like a suburban town nice
yeah it's just like a little kind of
regular town yeah I see a sign for is
amazing
just stop there's eight blocks go
through it get back on the to send you
go see all four stoplights Hey
go to the Carl's jr. he'd go nuts man
welcome to Monrovia that's goes happy
birthday baby
Dave she seemed like she was having fun
Dana was supposed to come and she did it
what one was it nobody on the road
you knew but she cuz that's when we I
was gonna go but that's when we had the
look at this dress you [ __ ] could I put
my son and you know he's gonna have like
really weird confidence because he's
picked constantly been dressed as a
female I know what you know what happens
when Mother's dress her sons it's
females they become serial killers right
you have a young serial killer race
she's a girl she has a vagina Oh
serial killers now girls can't be serial
killers you anti-feminists dirtbag well
which of these seat upsets do you think
is most likely like the big ones
Raptors magic our Raptors gonna win that
everybody calm down
I don't know man I don't know magic
they're tough they both laugh they got
none to lose and that's what right ya
know it's one zero good for the Clippers
and they play tonight they play today
what's the other game Spurs Nuggets
that'd be a big upset Spurs are leading
1-0
I think the Nuggets win that one but
saying that I told you it's gonna be a
dogfight that one is the hardest one
then poorly I think I think
Portland beats him tonight I think
Portland ready to go to the next level
aah Portland's the underdog yeah I think
Portland I think part of the ones that
series I was wondering I don't know well
I mean they're Portland's higher-seeded
team but who knows I think the Spurs
might be giving Diaw I think that
Nuggets could be in trouble this series
yeah possibly
I mean they're Bryant like they're just
a new team I love yoga Joe oh well I
can't believe you slipped to the second
round little watch tonight got Polly oh
by the way here's a real shocker in
sports
Zions going pro really no [ __ ]
how's that news you're looking at coming
in they already talking about is he a
generational player already guy think
played in the NBA yet it was that all
the time dude they did that with LeBron
they did that just let him play some
[ __ ] games first we let me know it
maybe he's injury prone or something
they just yes Pierre just wants to talk
about anything
ESPN just likes to smell of their own
breath it's a it's a [ __ ] they're the
word I just say stuff they're the worst
then they were talking about don't say
in sports news don't say my could beat
might I want to hear you don't want to
hear your theories ESPN did Kobe Bryant
ruin the Lakers that's what Max
Kellerman was saying that he thought
Kobe Bryant ruined the Lakers because of
his contract and then I guess just his
looming over the whole process now sure
yes yeah he ruined it by taking all that
money so they couldn't get anybody
that's a good way to get me to like her
right right and it's just like dude
looking like Tim Duncan Dirk Nowitzki no
God those guys took less money that
tried to put teams around them
do you a dude Tony I'm [ __ ] Tom Brady
yeah
same deal Michael Jordan didn't start
making tons of cash till the end because
he's making so much money off the off
the court
he didn't milk them so they could get
other players he sits at those max 30
mils towards the end yeah not early
though ice what you mean you know and
dude okay you know I just want I want to
not want to know his career salary was
I'm kind of interested in it so so I
mean Kobe oh dude Kobe ran people out
Kobe
let the coaching staff is dividing
players would he hop would I talk to
players I don't mind the fighting
because that's kind of spunk but they
keep Rob polenka is going to nobody the
NBA likes them
the GM's don't like them they're not
going to do deals with them I like that
step Michael Jordan made more money last
year than in his entire NBA playing
career making remain running for what
George a billion yeah probably
Hanes underwear let's see Jordans ever
gotten that's with the Wizards his
average salary with the Wizards was a
million he took a million into with the
Wizards that was his [ __ ] off I was just
gambling money yeah spends that gambling
on golf
especially 15 whatever that was 17 years
ago that's all so much money like a
millions a lot now but then it was crazy
yeah I know he was probably just giving
him a break though right cuz he was the
GM or whatever uh let's see sign of
eight year who do you think made the
most eight so that was this cuz you know
it might not be Jordan non-ahmadi money
not included just NBA contract wise in
their career who do you think oh I mean
it's gonna be a weird one you know me
well I mean there's gonna get lapped
right now cuz these guys are the highest
played players by season so here you go
every season today yeah this is a tough
curry should be Russell was a soldier
wait he doesn't get that a year yeah
yeah these are yearly salaries go 30 he
gets [ __ ] 37 37 last year it was
Steph Curry at 34 two years ago it was
LeBron at 30 then Al Horford right
behind him at 26 2015 16 it was Kobe
Bryant with 25 mil 14:15 Kobe Bryant Wow
13 14 Kobe Bryant with 30 wow he got
Bank back then that's a lot of money
back 1213 Kobe Bryant 30 let's see it's
Kobe Kobe Kobe was murdering it kg was
like I remember when Garnett got that
big contract yeah and because everyone
was saying that was gonna be the last
one of those cars he got one of those
max contracts Kevin Garnett was on 24
and oh eight oh nine Barnett again 2306
or seven cards now that Kobe must have
[ __ ] really milk
how the priorities have changed you see
us all got guards now in small yeah well
one like Shaq would come through he'd
get that money he also got to Kim Bay
you got Jermaine O'Neal to get healthy
he'd remain come on dikembe mutombo he
was at the game last night four or five
he was getting that kind of money keep
going oh we were still in the league
enough what what game was that what game
that he was at Dikembe Mutombo to one
Howard it was he was it the cell phone
camp that was in the league in 2003 yeah
Jeff last year yeah yeah yeah why cuz
they were like hey there's the Kim Bay
Mutombo and I said I only know who that
is from your podcast that's what I do
all centers Ewing O'Neal Robinson
Garnett morning Juwan Howard Elijah want
matumbo Jason Williams is the first non
Center if you go back there and also the
only guy on there to shoot somebody with
a shotgun I don't know I said Scottie
Pippen - okay so Jordan his last year
was supposedly Scottie Pippen's got that
big party today yeah the biggest dick
yeah I've heard that have you heard that
yeah
maybe from you though going dude I want
to see what Jordan Maine Jordan got 33
no I mean 96 he's not even in the top
look at that he signed an extension in
88 though an eight-year contract in 88
that he paid they paid him 25 mil over
eight years
oh that's chump change yeah 25 mil over
eight knows his fifth year as a pro and
he got 25 mil over eight years in eight
years - 25 mil a year or 25 over 25
million over eight the next eight years
it doesn't say per you that suckers
money yeah that's like three mil a year
he was probably making seven million a
year off the Air Jordans back then yeah
and McDonald's oh yeah he was a he was
the first super [ __ ] when it came to
marketing and advertising there was
nuttin Jordan witness old watches cuz
Chevrolet he had car dealerships I mean
there weren't even his car dealerships
he was just doing like
Chicago and Chevrolet yeah I mean by
heat him yeah
Kobe sucks I [ __ ] hate Kobe in 91 he
was making three point two five
not a lot it says nothing close to what
he's worth the Chicago of course one
prominent West Coast GM said Jordans
worth the entire salary CAF I will say
this dude it was a hot a Sports
highlight of my life and longevity-wise
to grow up in that area and to be in my
sport you know to be 12 when they
drafted Jordan and to spend my teenage
years and college years and early
adulthood getting to watch Jordan did
you go to games oh I went to probably 60
Bulls games growing up to be fairly have
Chicago Stadium that's before the United
Center I went to United Center too but I
probably went to as many in this games
at Chicago Stadium when it was the dream
team no well no but never really was a
tree mascot that was like the Olympic
team but okay but uh we know Jordan pee
when they just had Jordan and Bob love
oh yeah all the time
Rodman all the time of it later but he
was Rodman yeah Rodman was layers are
wearing this black jerseys black jersey
yeah there wasn't anyone they don't like
them cuz I remember like my whole family
like them talking about her where you
were from I hated him when they were
stomping the Hornets in the playoffs
that was the only time Larry Johnson to
get hurt man Oh although such a good
team but you went with Mugsy Bogues
would SOT I don't know I know so it's
like Mugsy bugs well yeah but the tiger
cat was only twelve point five million
oh he was getting her team that's what
it says the manager said he's worth the
entire salary cap or 12.5 million which
is can that be that's like a million
bucks a player
well the he said he bought the Bulls for
less than 20 million dollars midway
through Jordan's rookie season that's
when Reinsdorf bought the Bulls for
twenty million that's crazy
bought the whole team yeah it's got it
that team's gotta be worth two hundred
million dollars yeah it was valued a
hundred million in 91 what's he worth
now easily a billion who Reinsdorf know
thank you both
Oh cuz I think about the socks - yeah
the Chicago Bulls are worth an estimated
2.9 billion fourth-most
what's the most expensive on New York
gotta be Lakers or Lakers there's I mean
dude this is how you go to [ __ ] right
now
gotta be Lakers oh they need a real GM
dude
one is the Knicks at 4 billion - is the
Lakers three point seven Golden State at
three holes at four we're clippers on
there
well the Clippers were bought for - yeah
I mean they have to be because they're
in LA yeah you would do oh let's see
Cleveland is twenty five surprised
Cleveland's got 34th yeah it might be
when LeBron was there when the story
came out yeah when I wonder how much
lost in five lawmakers Houston or a
Clippers eight there you go and the nets
are worth more how great was it watching
Palmer celebrate guys gonna have a heart
attack Braun the best owners plow he has
one of those G buddies I love I do love
him I hope you guys won those pills you
can put on your tongue if you're ever
gonna have a heart attack easy to
celebrate er having a [ __ ] stroke he's
gonna be like this after the game we did
really good today he goes crazy yeah
just this isn't from last night he seems
like a fun billionaire look at him
that's him right there he used to do
this for like Mike received a check
right there she's on every they just
parade her everywhere she does every
commercial for them I love him he's a
limber happy old man the by he would
become alone
he was like Microsoft's again you know
was with Bill Gates but he would come
out and they introduced like Windows or
whatever and be doing this exact same
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
crazy video let me see so what do you
got okay so who do you think any upsets
happen in the first round do you think
at all look at this wow this is no
selling us some Groupon that's another
person that it's all everything
look at him this is him rolling out some
[ __ ] Microsoft [ __ ] and look at it
look at this crazy bastard that's look
at that he looks weird with hair he has
no rhythm like I can not dance I like
I'm bald better like that you call that
with hair cuz it's a little thicker I
mean but he's like totally ball yeah
that looks like if you have a
billionaire dad he's a [ __ ] prick
that's true so it did you the double way
you can afford really fun nannies you
could have you've seen this kid that kid
you get this guy coming in in the
morning when you're talking is like
imagine going from being a billionaire
son in Seattle to a billionaire son in
LA like the amount of [ __ ] chaos
you're gonna get into is unbelievable
he's so different than Bill Gates to
like that when they when they kind of
handed off their polar opposites what is
it oh here we go here's him this is like
Conan talking about his crazy baby let's
see if they do a clip area yeah he's
[ __ ] nuts
the own sports team surgeon doctor
clippers okay hold on that was a crime
looking at crying yeah after that whole
scandal but the Clippers a couple of
years ago he's yeah thank God what a
maniac and now the NBA fine if you a
billionaire wouldn't you make sure you
were in like really good shape no well I
bet that you've a [ __ ] awful hair I
dress like [ __ ] and I just bang Penn's
daughter not her what happened to the
guy that had this oh you talk about a
girl can't face Weiser girl fixing the
visor girlfriend so I'm going to the
game tomorrow
I used my tickets that's Thursday right
not tomorrow yeah okay I think I'm in a
different game yeah I was like wow your
house I damned man you're gonna sports
games everyday yeah here we go
ya see geek yeah that were you do what's
the guy's name
sure dog we got sure dog on the phone oh
I forgot that's what you know these are
funny memories these are not funny
memories but then you get mad at us so
it's funny to look back on and then
you're like it's your fault you leave so
guys tomorrow night I'm going to see the
Clippers in their playoff game super
excited we're back at the Staples Center
and I wanna see key that's right
see geek if you ever need tickets for
that or anything else make sure to check
out our sponsor Shiki for a long time
buying tickets has been really difficult
and annoying and just it's annoying it's
annoying let's admit it and you get rip
can easily get ripped off yeah get rid
oh yeah I got ripped off before I knew
and off Oh Georgia Dome yeah got ripped
off twice it is for the same game I got
ripped off the Staples Center yeah
dude I've been ripped off the Staples
Center as well we're not gonna get
ripped off cheeky guy took my money and
ran away the ticket industry's been
really bad before see cake there's a
bunch of companies have been around
forever but don't really care about
making the experience easier for the
customers
aha well seeking is tea company that
customers come first with more than
50,000 five-star reviews in the Apple
Store seeking is focused on making an
experience as easy as possible Shiki
pulls in millions of tickets from all
the web rate each deal on a scale of one
to ten displace an interactive seat map
so simple it's it's like it's so simple
to find what you're looking for green
dots are good deals red dots are
overpriced right I mean we've done that
before you go here's a red dot stick
some $1,600 for a courtside seat for
this four Clippers Thursday yeah
Clippers Thursday
hey go stock there's a boxing yeah there
is some coming up okay think I mean TBC
I actually got my phone guys and it's by
far these who I've found the shop for
tickets I in fact I've just you see keek
to buy tickets to the
clipper game yes best of all my
listeners our listeners Jason's
listeners can get $10 off their first
seat geek purchase somebody hit me up
this weekend and said hey what's the
code for for a CTE car they're trying to
go to the loma chenko fight and got
tickets for 60 bucks
so they got tickets for 50 bucks use the
promo code punch-drunk that's one word
for $10 off your first purchase you can
you can use it that for tickets
I mean concert tickets sports comedy
whatever
remember the promo code punch-drunk for
$10 off your first purchase so you can
go see the Dodgers play for sixteen
dollars it's $26 you get $10 off ha
laughing any boxing yeah there's that
PBC I was talking about Danny Garcia is
fighting on the 20th not here for that
one go to a Dodger already who who's the
guy that went up and fought the
undefeated guy what Garcia was that
Mikey Mikey Garcia Oh Mikey Garcia could
Mikey fight lomachenko I don't think
anybody could yeah III think Mikey
Garcia too big for him huh Mikey
Garcia's fight nannies baby right that's
right
micro yeah the baby rude I'd love to see
baby boxing and I'm swear to [ __ ] god
yeah because no one's done it yet we got
to start training Larry
little Larry get some gloves on his
hands Mikey went Dana did call max Mikey
for like her first six months of life
huh who did you and Dana
you'd be like what's your baby a Mikey
how's my nice Mickey doin what about
what about two grown men boxing but
instead of gloves these babies the best
thing I've ever heard who'd they fight
yeah they could fight yeah I'd love to
see that I don't think Mikey's got
anything for Hamlin you ducktail baby on
each hand and then then box it's like
the best yeah but let me chinko kill
Bravo Aaron he gets a raise Lohmann she
knows it he this guy did you watch that
fight I love it you're nearly killed a
guy yeah I mean Friday yeah it wasn't
yeah watched it I felt bad for the guy I
watched it the next day
he's getting paid yeah he's not enough
that was one of those knockouts were you
like he might be dead yeah okay this is
a knockout did you see the fight Sam
then you saw the [ __ ] knockout yeah
yeah so we don't need to show you 14
minutes that's probably just gonna be
incredulous some guy talking like I
expected
man when Tyson said he broke his back
[Music]
Tyson Oh what do you mean pegye for the
listener low Michiko is beating the [ __ ]
out of a guy on a video yeah I mean
strategical yeah he's he's moving man
here he might be the hairy guy here's he
just faceplant
he's completely knocked out before he
even hits the yeah I think pound for
pound he's the best now right no Michiko
already knocked him down before this and
now he's got him on the ropes just
pounding his ass no I mean no but the
guys covering up they provide a stable
center referee probably should've ended
the fight the first times guys guy he's
busted up oh you were out of town I was
like why didn't you go here we go this
is the Johnny why didn't you go what to
this yeah uh I'll tell you why I didn't
go cuz I'm embarrassed about it I
thought it was Saturday night
Oh smart and I and I had that and I was
doing the UFC theory by party and watch
this Sam yeah just faceplant you know
you're [ __ ] up when you go face-first
that's when you're really not that yeah
when you like put yourself in doggystyle
position okay that's how baby he just
clipped him right in the temple it
didn't look like a big blow but it
caught him perfect right on the temple I
mean when he rose over you can see he's
just like what years oh dude they had to
lift him up on the stool and he's still
ain't right he tries to stand up that's
cuz it's like one of those right there's
a real wrecking out tomorrow I mean dude
he is ow
we got a dead body that's like yeah
that's like a what a Bill Cosby
daters and they rolling overlooking I
mean he's [ __ ] up or off today like
this ref cam isn't resting up great they
put like a camera on like I guess on his
bow tie or something so I thought it was
I thought that it was um Saturday and I
just turned it out of my head cuz I
can't go because I'm doing the UFC fight
companion on thank you everybody that
came to the dojo to watch the UFC with
us that was super fun show was great so
thanks to the dojo and anybody that came
out but and then it turns out it's like
Friday night I start seeing on Twitter
the results of the fight oh my [ __ ] that
was tonight things were expensive even
on less expensive professionally darn
near they had a really good crowd though
like per Staples Center for just la la
fans that's one sport that they really
know well that tells myeloma chinko is a
name now this is a boxing town for
certain No Mas I don't know if that's
because of the high amount of Latino
community here because that's just a big
sport in there horse but this town knows
boxing pretty well I wouldn't even say
this is a it's getting to be a football
town yes be a ram sir charger for all
times I think even if the Chargers won
the Super Bowl the Rams are still
running the show I think one more boxing
I have what was go to UFC to I'd real
quick before we get on that there was
this Truax fought Peter Quillin on
Saturday and he got just the same kind
of cut as max Holloway did like in the
same place at the same time they both
got cut it almost the exact same time
because I was watching one fight on my
phone and I look at you multitasking
this cut was amazing just an art they
had to end the fight here it is in the
fight in the second round yeah but
remember what was that box with his
whole head swelled up like that Hasim
Rahman Hasim Rahman
that's a nasty cut no no that was it was
I seen Rahman I'll show you it was
against Holyfield Yandy where do you see
this scar cuz that's pretty yeah that's
bad huh yeah wait to see this guy's head
from this fight
when I see that like how does that even
happen there you go Sam oh damn dude he
had a new head and then he just kept
getting it that was homey feel right
then he kept punching it you hit it with
a [ __ ] solid right every time and
you're like everybody watching it was
like stop punching him there but yeah
that's almost exactly where Hollow I got
cut except on the other side and it
happened like seconds apart I was
watching both fighters really weird I
don't know we all should just go in
there like up in the frigid start
getting stuff like ooh it's like when
every somebody gets out of a car and
then the driver gets out of the car and
I thought but the car's still going
Tesla's so [ __ ] it's the coolest car
do you love that car awesome
it's super cool tiffany has got the same
car oh really oh yeah say he got it cuz
he liked her dance dance all you got to
do is show red man some shiny gadgets or
some trick your trickery [ __ ] also he
was a new robotic thing I'm in he was on
the road with kill Tony and he tweeted
that he was it's the first time I've
ever missed my car oh he said when he
got back from from being on the road
that he just sat in his car for two
hours not even driving it just sitting
in his car it's like the iPhone of court
cuz like I love my iPhone I [ __ ] love
it well you're the same kind of guy as
he is yeah if you had the money you have
a Tesla and I don't even like to drive
I'll walk it you don't even have to
drive that one you just get in the
backseat ticket now I could move into
your Tesla that's not take me to Wendy's
and then you just take a nap and you
wake up at the way I'm really looking
forward to that
yeah the driverless I mean I like
driving but not in the city it's a pain
in the ass yeah it's gotta be I mean do
there like like manual takeovers like if
let's say you see it you're heading
towards the cliff is there a break that
you can hit it you just gotta trust yeah
right as soon as you turn it turns like
as soon as you interact with it it goes
off oh so you can okay like autopilot is
okay I don't mind that in fact the
autopilot now won't even work unless you
put your hands on the
because they had so many people taking
dumb at these retards taking video they
should have breathalyzers like you know
taking selfies with their hands on
movies in the backseat
they should have breathalyzer sore you
blowing it it'll just go nah dude I'm
taking you home but seriously that's the
great application right because you can
be drunk and you can home say yeah
that's what a bruise for - yeah but you
guys driving cars don't count was
against a DUI oh I'm sure they would but
how could that count why wouldn't you
just say because you might have to take
her it could be a technology failure
it's not satellite whoo I'm saying you
would get a DUI but read ban like said
it as a joke but I think red bean really
would go drunken is our home self drives
he goes home his car does itself Drive
just launched this thing yourself drunk
drives that car this thing called summon
and then just an upgrade to all the cars
that are out there and so you're the
grocery store your car's parked in the
[ __ ] parking lot you forget where it
is you just stand in the front you hit
the button and it comes to you the
[ __ ] car comes to you yes it's
amazing
Knight Rider come to life Wow I don't
they are gonna turn again my buddies got
a [ __ ] old dodge that's haunted it's
like two ghosts in there all the time
it's just the worst you want to hear
your ghost story - goes [ __ ] in an
old Dodge you know the old saying
yeah they Clyde that out classic saying
my dad is the most sober morning boring
boring boring Krishna I know and he was
driving them the most sober yet like
sober minded oh really like he's like a
Christian dude like really sure dad ever
just get hammered not not anymore I'm
probably in his young days he was a wild
man oh okay he's a solid dude anyway so
he was driving near my house one time
and late at night around midnight
driving it is kind of weird bridge and
he looked in his back seat and he saw
this woman white hair red eyes glowing
on his looking at him with this evil
face in his rear view mirror and he
almost [ __ ] himself and laughing a meter
that is terrified him in his entire life
and but he thought maybe I you know I'm
a how old how old is he he's 56 now no
at this time when he thirty okay he had
like a psychotic break
like he was thinking maybe I had a
psychotic break you know like that I
lose my minor because but then his
cousin this guy also called Johnny are
you running the [ __ ] South's called
Johnny oh my dad's called Johnny big
Johnny Lil Jon he comes to my dad and
says dude I can't barely talk about this
the guy started crying a little bit
who's this guy now he's cousin funny
another day another Jenny is this guy a
real or as this guy ghost he's he says
he says dude I was driving near your
house over that bridge and I saw it he
saw the same thing and this guy can't
even talk like I tried to talk to him
about it and he's eyes just well up and
if any just wait so it wasn't in your
car I was outside it was inside the car
in the backseat yeah exactly and they
independently like managed to talk about
did they see it through the mirror they
looked back rearview mirror that is
really sir I would crash the car yeah I
defy this other guy can't seriously
though like not even he can't talk about
it he's like I've tried to talk to him
in his hands are just like like that why
does anybody go there and trying to like
just sitting well they demolish the
bridge and thing and my dad says it
doesn't happen anymore now they're like
too many ghost stories I gotta get what
would eat you and he describes it he
says what you would see is like a weird
smoke there and he swears one time it
was it's kind of at a turn he almost
drove off the bridge like what's gonna
crash yeah and then something just
pulled it back on oh so she's a nice
girl somebody there's a graveyard like
literally a hundred yards away you know
she probably died when they probably
built that bridge on top of her when she
was taking a nap yeah could be
I mean hey if you were in a Brady one
you want people to know about it if you
were trapped inside a bridge so wait a
minute no there's a disturbing fact
that's kind of got glossed over here
your dad's only 56
my mom's I think 54 yeah he might be my
mom my mom had me very young yeah my mom
had me oh my parents were like 20 that's
like how it was back then though now you
have kids at like 35 yeah like you're 19
you pop them out you yeah you're 18 you
start coming in people
yeah and old do you think I am here 50
well just 56 I mean 20 years older than
me so he'd barely be my dad
he was if that would make him like 21 25
when I was born okay 25 and you were
born something like that [ __ ] my mom was
nine when me my dad 73 like yeah that's
crazy
74 yeah my mom was nine when she had me
and my dad was 47 are you my real come
here and he might be like 59 she I don't
know man I'm supposed to know how old
everybody know I always I can't
just family kept asking me how old my
parents were I'm like I have to like do
math right now I don't know any of my
family's birthdays like no no that's bad
we're all really gone you didn't even
know your own parents age I know what
their birthdays in the year they were
born but I don't know how old their I
have to do the math all right
interesting mr. Koester where'd you go
no we kept we waited for you okay
respect you thank even though you just
walked off and we thought you weren't
bathroom I did I'd the pee pee pee yes I
got 20 minutes that was in 20 minutes
how long who cares anyways quick recap
my dad was born in the 40s in his
forties [ __ ] funny today
coming in hot Aaron Aaron some fire
Aaron what's going out your wife is it
working out yeah she's great
sure at what she tells me that's what
you say no chat ports
she's our number one poster in the
pledge she's always in there going down
to [ __ ]
I know yeah she's always askin if
anybody's a divorce attorney
but yeah I've wanted to do a little
short look up minutes talking those guys
about then going out to that place
seeing if anybody else has seen the same
thing that would be interesting Joe when
you're there for two weeks yeah there
was a place like that in my hometown to
already said that it's lady hung herself
and if you parked your car there and put
it in neutral they said she would push
it yeah it's got like up this hill and
it day we had work I did it before and
you are going up hills well it's
supposed to
those things are optical illusions or
something like that because it's a call
to gravity hill and it's there you know
said to be haunted there's one in mind
okay well there's like a whole only but
well no it's not wrong no I believed it
was real I never believed it was real no
but it is it's like yeah it's kind of it
does work but I didn't think was it so
coming it's because a woman can't push a
car up a hill that's my point I feel
like oh there's this big strong guy cool
but no ghosts woman is pushing a car
there's even weaker and Daddy ray we
made the list tiny little Scotland
County gravity he'll go to Indiana
Missouri in California this is
fascinating
yeah Indiana Mooresville is that it
no we're maybe Michigan it might've been
in Michigan - because I lived on the
border
mee-shee and Blaine Township a row City
nope when neither one does you're a
filthy life hell no it really there's
one in Altadena there's one in more
honored but there's no way a woman's
gonna push a car up hills close to my
head here
you should go to it okay it's one it's
10 54 East Loma Alta Drive I feel like I
do remember people talking about that in
high school like let's go to that hill
yeah yeah this is the thing you Dodgers
I got there and smoke at Joey and that's
where people like it's like in the high
school you have like seven people in
your car you're just doing nothing yeah
it's let you drive in circles it's the
same story in my town it's a woman that
pushes the carpet because her kids got
killed at the intersection well there's
this really cool old tree right where
you starting line is and they always
said that she hung herself there what a
beautiful landmark ya know Wow here's
the one in Altadena guess you just go
there and yeah it's weird they're called
gravity Hill everywhere that's one must
be some sort of phenomenon yeah we all
have one like we're weaker yeah yeah
there's baby powder on the hood and his
LeBron around oh yeah baby powder that's
supposed to be a thing you can do you
can see handprints and baby powder what
that's like a common part of the myth
you put baby powder on the hood or trunk
of your car
oh there are suppose to be fingerprints
on
I wrote that people are stupid
that's how bored boring life can be is
people just make this crazy [ __ ] up
Holloway versus bill you do some scrap
what you row you watch the hell yeah
where'd you watch it at cuz you're out
is that right oh we had it on our little
lot oh yeah yeah watch out yeah cuz your
wit Bravo I know he's gonna try to miss
it
I think Holloway is in trouble I think
he's gone I don't think he's done I just
don't I mean he moved up a whole weight
class you know that's not even though
weight class is his boat yeah he was
trying to do to both yeah exactly I just
I think he doesn't need to be moving up
that everyone does that yeah well I'm
just glad he's not close enough anyway
he woulda killed Keith khabees gonna
destroy Porter yeah well I mean he would
have killed Holloway I mean yeah he
might have like snapped his neck so Ben
Askren I think has a chance against
capiz I wasn't that impressed with him
in his home right yeah but aspirin yeah
but that's always your first fight in
the Octagon okay hey Sam you're not an
either of my shots okay I'm cool I'm
cool here's my knee hold the mic across
the room um I thought that uh I thought
I mean that bad um what's his name how
do you pronounce his name Israel even
that was hard for me I don't even like
to try the lattice Anya
no Sonya that gassim fight was good dude
they're behaved like I've said this on
the show before for like the last couple
of fights of his he's my new favorite
fighter right now that was a neat humble
he's nice he's not any immigrant
mentality he's charismatic I didn't go
to interview was that the best file in
the car I didn't see the early fights
duh the Castleman yep and there was the
fight before the main fight you didn't
see that yeah I did see that I didn't
see the earlier three earlier fights
were pretty boring in my opinion what
that real I did see Jovan I didn't see
any of the first uh say proof I was okay
oh I thought because he what's that
I thought somebody told me that you want
I didn't realize like Krylov or whatever
one that's good it's a mean-looking dude
uh yeah you got a minute tapped him out
very pretty much rear naked
what is that tattoo that's a weird
tattoo oh that's a white power tattoo
that's Illuminati it does look like I
don't know if that's you that looks like
a prison
Orr's like white supremacist a 2px and
it looks like a bunch of what are those
trolleys it's like a German cross the
typewriter like the weird tail do
tattoos wings on their [ __ ] well this
dude's got like one of those tat those
scars that they do in college you know
yeah fraternities yeah mega moose they
did those in my college man does his
tattoos and ban Tate Tate Oh No
oh it must be some friend what's a band
well I'm sure would be in another
language if it was that Oh whatever
language that is it says ban trans right
that first fight was a good decent fight
I enjoyed that fight Joe bond and grant
that's controversial isn't it did you
think job on one I thought it was close
it was weird that if I scored it I would
either would have had it a draw or job
on winning but somebody had it all three
rounds two Jovan and the other two had
it two rounds to one for grant how the
[ __ ] does that happen I'm gonna why was
there so much discrepancy even if you
had a two-one job on referee should be
digit yeah they should let nobody have
the kid television in front of them
would no sound just so he could watch it
there and see live they do that in lower
levels they let the you know the referee
be the judge who's got a better angle
than the phone I don't think
Holloway's John I think he is gonna
rethink his plan to move it up in weight
class yeah I'm sure for him
I'm gonna watch today I was at anything
how is my baby's birthday party I didn't
watch the fight yeah the baby yeah
so I'm gonna watch today but I read all
about them a little highlight I think
they beat the [ __ ] out of each other I
heard it was amazing it was great but I
just want to know your guy's opinion why
he did yeah yeah yeah because so many
people don't act that I read said that
he won two rounds and Holloway went
pouria came out he was was super active
to start we everybody thought he was
gonna get punched out like I mean he was
that active to start it I mean even even
even Holloway admitted it you know I saw
the thing where they were shaking his
yeah did we all see Theo von oh I heard
that everyone could hear him yelling
yeah funny yeah so I only need to watch
the last two fights right yeah okay but
the whole at our UFC you could all see
him watch party and show somebody
noticed him in the crowd in our crowd
watching the fights and then we had a
turn the sound up and you could [ __ ]
absolutely could totally him every time
you were deceived you know I hear Theo
everybody in which here in the audience
that head on his podcast that Shaab text
him like I can hear you get your [ __ ]
together because he was yelling crazy
stuff like kick him in the neck or like
this would be working with Rogen or was
he just there him and Santino I think
when he wasn't on the road though he
said he just wanted to go because he's
friends with Poirier and he just asked
Rogan if he could go I think him in
Santino went or Santino might have been
in Atlanta already I'm not sure this
fight was good he's special man he's a
great counter puncher he has great head
movement we're talking to him about
Israel Aaron Sonya oh he goes when he he
said that win in his press conference
afterwards Israel goes yeah he goes you
know there's a good fight it was real
nice about
Gastelum and wasn't talking [ __ ] and he
goes we knew we were it like in a battle
because yo he went to the ground then I
hit it with a let's play that moment
right there and then he got up and we
looked at each other and made eye
contact both of us were like [ __ ] well
and then afterwards he I guess was it
rain or whatever
called over and he took the belt like
this and got down all the way on his
face oh yeah and laid the belt in front
of the guy like whoever this guy is I
must miss train I know it's his lover
yeah it could be his boyfriend yeah but
I mean like completely oh prayers
interesting yeah good card it was a good
card I thought it was awesome right the
two main fights look great and that's
all you know he's got a lot of problems
right now a lot of problems 237 to met
not too many fights not enough great
fighters well I get that there's so many
money and more belts they need every
five pounds there's so much money to be
enough lighters yeah I don't know man I
miss the days when it was one free one a
month one pay-per-view a month that was
very easy to navigate through okay and
stack the cards with everybody and okay
but there's too much money to be made
good now it's I don't know Overeem
chakra or then if you're gonna make a
pay-per-view answer DAC the [ __ ] out of
the car
Nami unis three four titles three four
four three four belts on the line once
his face told me this was a fight night
but it's not it's UFT 237 Nami unison
and Rowley
yeah May 11th I mean this is already
middle of May fight night fight night
well that's a good fight that's a really
good fight yeah that's a really good
fight oh that's the guy from the
ultimate [ __ ] I love how their name is
to be now enough that's gotta hurt I
mean to the top I want to see what I'm
into the card for 237 Overeem is free
pardon the Overeem one is a fight night
uh yeah Wow okay I always liked watching
Overeem fight I don't know why but
aren't none of them for you don't you
need a ESPN Plus yes well yeah I told
Jeff we need to splurge in $4.99 a month
because we're losing it as fans and
where'd you get it
I already subscribe to the magazine yes
be in the magazine and all that's just
yeah yeah if you do that who's all on
you 237 scarred there Jen ah let's see
no me understand draw they are rose
spiders fighting again he's got fight
every other month though he's irrelevant
now it's too high age yeah look out look
how old much older out it looks wow look
at that
he has always looked he claims he's like
29 and he's 45 he didn't get carded as a
baby they did that South Korea things
who's Aldo fighting Nikolai Volkoff
Alexander Volkov ski I mean that's I
don't care too much for that card
he looks pixelated how do you have
wrinkles in your cheek he looks like
he's in Mike Tyson's punch-out I've
never seen my word wrinkles like right
here 80 big knot I thought there's your
daddy no dude I vote against anybody
with a man bun [ __ ] man buns I'm so
tired of this bad haircut
I literally there's other than rows
there's not a fight on that card I care
and there's a girl fights the girl
headline ones never do well anyway so
it's like you need to make it the best
card ever for anyone to by that I mean
Aldo is irrelevant now
spider ill relevant now of course I'd
love to see them fight it love to see
him win but they're not striking any
fear in anybody that's a weird-looking
dude this is a senior citizens and then
you got Big Nog this is like the senior
citizens tour of the UFC he is 42 I
remember Dana White said years ago he
was allowed to fight anymore because
he's too old she's still fighting he
gets a concussion putting his mouthpiece
in it's like they're seniors tour Dana
White done giving a noogie arrow fight
Nogueira fights that's three or four
years ago this photo I mean this guy's
just done but what can you do I don't
want to see him fight ever again Dino
White told mm-hm it was like really bad
well that's one of the suit he's done
since then maybe he had like I just need
your quick paycheck
please I feel bad for these guys yes
because no like BJ Penn all the ones
that I can't let it go I understand why
they're doing it but it is very
depressing to watch Anderson Silva
depressing okay so he won he did win an
8 lot that default Alvie so Dana White
just doesn't watch she's like I can't
watch this yeah he's fought three times
since he was on the Rousey Korea and
2015 that must have been the one where
he lost - yeah yeah then he beat Patrick
Cummins I don't know Patrick
is he good you know who you'll recognize
them oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I like
that guy Bader and then I don't I don't
remember this fight at all I don't know
it was on a fight night okay he
technical knockouts lost and won the
last three fights interesting what do
you what did you say Sam Steve's coming
did he say he was coming yeah the bag of
bets podcast host yeah ha ha ha go to
I'll go to Tiger Woods how great yeah
you and I were Texan during that that
was incredible Joe you really say you
just know it's a bunch of nuts on your
shoulder let me tell you did you like
how many times have you said that deep
yeah I texted Sam amazing something he's
like hey you watch yeah I missed the
whole thing because they had a rain
thing and they moved it up like yeah my
mouth was a stripper hours you don't get
up till well dude it started 6 a.m. on
those goes girlfriend that's not that
doesn't Sam's right you do have stripper
hours they started at 6 a.m. on the west
coast to be fair you were watching at 6
a.m. he was East Coast uh oh
she was an outbound are you damn please
oh you were back yet and they moved it
up the Braves play without any problem
that night she runs his restaurants or
some definitely he doesn't look like the
his normal the judges chick he's bad
chick looks like she loves coke and
[ __ ] bright she looks
those are the biggest [ __ ] glasses
we're seeing my life look at that Wow it
was like Brad William I know it's
amazing
Oh tongue down her throat
did you watch yeah we actually did have
this on what does but a lot of sports
alas a lot of comebacks this week yeah I
mean well I'm super happy came back
Clippers something better happy for him
that's almost I do
he's obviously great for golf yeah oh
yeah I mean they want him more that he's
more important to golf than any fighter
is in the UFC to the UFC you know in
Augusta is applauding a black man like
that that he's great for like he's gotta
be out because they weren't they love
those guys around there still aren't
having like I mean they don't like that
at all when black people I think they've
all compartmentalized that he's not
black in some way in their head yeah
he's a brand you know I mean I think
they somehow he gets a like a get out of
jail card on the blackest you know well
you know his dad was kind of black and
his mom wasn't even black at all so he's
not really one of those he's looking
more a that's what they do at Augusta
yeah he gets to look at more Asian as he
ages look he needs to shave that hair
gotta shave it
shave it dude so much better when they
let it go we really like it you like
this if you're balding I think it's so
much better to shave like he looks like
kind of like a black guy there and now
his eyes are super Asian looking yeah
isn't that weird I think he's high on
the one on the right that's why he's
probably gotten plastic surgery and on
top of that he's a she Asian okay Jordan
yeah that's one more decline where
Jordan was a great Adam the minute his
hairline started going by hair
he made it cool to be bald Jordan yeah
and then he brought the Hitler mustache
back which it didn't the Jordan have
here in college I don't think so right
absolutely when you started going bald
he had a hair for I don't remember years
you're just so used to him being bald
Syria like I'm like 88 I see a random 88
huh
yeah he had the tiny little hair right
yeah I mean that's but that's that's 88
by
there's times we had a lot of hair look
like Michael Jackson hair and me there I
don't believe he had hair I'm Jesse
where he shaved okay 86 he's got a good
head you're lucky yet he's got a head
eighty some people have like light bulbs
for a head and they look [ __ ] creepy
86 still got good hairline
yeah 88 dunk contest yet hair 87 is
where he starts to shave it really close
here we go yeah yeah that's where you
started good you can see we're starting
to fan out a little bit right there
yeah like 89 probably I bet he's bald
okay we saw 8800 high here I think yeah
yeah okay yep and go high go back to
that picture I can't believe I know all
of Jordans hair lines go down how hot go
up go up how high oh yeah that was a
poster I had look at that if you went to
McDonald's you could but you could get
those posters it's a free I'm such a
degenerate I thought you meant high off
weed yeah my guy was like oh he's stoned
over here do you think Tiger ever wins
another one yeah another major another
maze well I think the race is on now you
had to catch Jack he moved up to like
number eight I think keep loading him up
with [ __ ] Waffle House [ __ ] while
Richards [ __ ] [ __ ] 88 you know make
it happen
you know he kind of wore out last year
he said he's doing like way less events
this year and he's just gonna focus on
the major and pick the ones yeah he's uh
far away is he from he's been too close
is he close to Jack at all overall cuz
Jack's got the most right yeah and
Tigers not far off I don't think he's
got eighteen and tigers at fifteen okay
he's got a good chance at that yeah see
if it's 15 yeah he's okay so he's gonna
get three more to tie Jack so forth or D
to avoid the pressure will be around for
that there's no way he went eleven years
without winning a major weapon hive
without playing at all he's been heard
five dozen years he didn't even play
golf you guys are crazy
although you know people say that the
[ __ ] with those women derailed his
career but he was really good right
after that he was like Player of the
Year the year after that he was the golf
player you
do they they don't count anything on the
seniors tour as winning a mage knob okay
Ren disease isn't coming for ten minutes
is he coming in yeah did he know you
said twelve tell me I mean don't if he's
driving okay Erin's gonna feel bad for
him at two our second guest in a row
that has a Tesla oh oh yes we he's got a
ball three friendly guests from now
yeah mile three yeah I think so I think
I think I heard red benzene but yeah
okay so talk about tiger a little bit
that was like when Malin re hit the ball
in the water I've never seen so many
people celebrate a guy [ __ ] up that
tells you how much everybody want Tiger
to win the Sam when Molinari hit the
ball in the water have you ever seen
golf fans especially a place like I got
to celebrate again
oh yeah dude they must have been like
just throw the game we'll take care of
you throw the game that was just [ __ ]
I mean dude the whole world wanted Tiger
to win then that guy hit stuff he has a
chance to get I think par or birdie and
he hits it and he misses the putt which
gives Tiger a third putt to be able to a
little more went wrangle room I heard a
interesting thought automatically
missing pots remember an odd naked gun I
think was Naked Gun they go to a boxing
match and they're sitting in the front
row ringside he goes this fight is gonna
be good both these guys are represented
by Don King ring the bell and one guy
swings doesn't even make contact the
other guy waits for a second it just
falls I need to start counting he didn't
even make contact with him maybe not Don
King maybe said the same guy but they
were clearly making a joke about Don
King I missed those movies were great
Leslie Nielsen Hey Oh Jay what's funny
in those Oh Jay well I really was dude
yeah he was great he was great yeah he's
in a wheelchair he went but he just kept
bad things just kept happening to him
yes Super Dave Osborne he goes off the
stadium yeah it's always like a dummy
yeah it was like the Super Dave I you
know I heard an interesting thought that
because they moved him into threesomes
because of the weather you know Tiger
was able to put pressure on both the
guys around him you know all those
people because there's
you said that have an old verbally when
you're standing around or with what like
with the with the the spectators and
yeah we're following him in the gallery
and all the cheering and [ __ ] like that
they think it kind of because everybody
I think the only two guys to shoot
around over par in that top group were
the two guys that were paired with Tiger
the everybody else in that top group
went under like they say this is
something like that like they had worse
days riding them yeah yeah exactly
everybody wanted you to get hit by
lightning at that point they just wanted
Titan Tiger has way more experience with
threesome stuff anyway I'm having a
shitty day Aaron's killing Aaron a
really good one what do you look it up I
was just gonna I wanted to see how they
shot our guys are with him I I stole
that stat froma I think Bill Simmons so
if it's wrong blame Bill Simmons I'm not
looking all right I do will blame Bill
Simmons and also big shout-out to
everybody in the NBA in the first at
least the first round or not first round
but the first game going all around on
hitting free throws this is the most
amount of made free throws I've seen it
I start seeing big men hitting foul shot
about time time we've been bitching
about those skilled now they're all
there's no reason you should not be able
to make a free throw what you think
about him bead though should they be
playing him winnings hurt like this they
can we play him like 18 minutes I would
pit I would try to trade him in the
offseason you were big your way I love
them dude why would you say oh he just
can't take the rigors man I would try to
get something for him early well you
could get a hell of a lot for my how
about Anthony Davis for Joel embiid yeah
I wouldn't have ice doing it why
wouldn't cuz Anthony Davis is a
generational talent he's amazing and
beat if he stayed healthy as a
generational not yet though he hasn't
proven it no he's good he's really good
en ad
yeah he's right there he's right there
unstoppable
dude nobody can stop and beat except
his knees oh I was gonna say do you want
mine
you need you need to be here for step
we're talking blood sacrifice you're
talking a little tiger right there told
you I get here well done and that's been
punch-drunk sports you don't tell me I
almost call I tried to call it really
minute yeah I know
were you supposed to be here twelve I
like this no he's not supposed to be air
twelve I told Sam I said I can get out
of this thing okay maybe around 12 will
you closer you're so nice but I was in
Pasadena drove here mmm and then I Drive
back but I love like [ __ ] dream home
me what this was about
I am bro enthralled with Tiger Woods
have you seen the commercial the new
Nike window plate Johnny thank you
that's why I said Johnny should be here
and I can get no I know but it was a
good man he still has a computer thanks
ok Johnny go vomit why not anyway it's
look did you watch
oh yeah I woke up at 5:45 in the moment
you really really lost
yeah I mean I was like look he's in the
final group so I'll know in the first
like couple hours like if this is like I
go back to bed uh-huh he shoots a six
over in the first three holes I'm gonna
go back to sleep
yeah right but you know it was he stuck
around stuck around stuck around right
hey man you know he was Francesco
Molinari was exactly what I thought is
gonna be unflappable 4:11 holes and then
that 12th hole which I don't know if you
guys are familiar with it at all but
it's that par 3 hole there's a basically
you it looks like there's not tee box
just like looks like people hanging out
like they are through some [ __ ] grant
beautiful grass down and then you have a
big like lake water bunker green like a
kidney and then bunker and you they
usually throw the pin up right over here
up on the upper like right and
everything if you don't get it to the
pin everything feeds right down and
it'll go right into the water right and
they just Jack Nicholas everyone said on
sight you don't even look on Sunday
don't look
aim for the middle of the green and hit
the ball at the middle of the green two
putts move on to the next hole but I and
I was shocked when it Francesca LeMond
already puts one in the water Brooks
capita one in the water and it's just
like an Tiger Woods you could have put a
blindfold on him like his dad told buddy
what put a blindfold on and hit a
hundred and forty-eight yard shot to the
middle of the [ __ ] green and he did
it like a ninja bro and that's when
that's when it all just went and that's
when everyone was like we got to chase
him now and then he just had a look he
had the look that he had a calm as [ __ ]
calm collected you know even when Pete
and you could tell people were yelling
[ __ ] at him he's owns that [ __ ] out but
everyone said well I mean you guys he's
one of the greatest is owning that job
we look we're you look up that computer
I look up that commercial Nike
commercial but uh
but and people were yelling [ __ ] you
follow ball barstool people yell [ __ ]
like you know you sign my tits and he
just like he'll crack up here and there
but there's like on Sunday wearing red
just completely a different a different
mindset one of the greats
you know he's Michael Jordan with a flu
he's you know Muhammad Ali went back
into the corner and that's it and it
just he flipped everyone else has got to
chase him JJ reddick in the playoff then
when he and then on and then on the next
par three at number 16 when he puts it
right at the top of the crest and knew
exactly what did you say I missed a lot
of death long long and he almost got a
hole-in-one on that hole ended up making
a birdie went up to I said this is it
he's gonna win yeah how excited were you
I mean except I yeah I was I was like
thrilled I was thrilled it was this road
for a lot of reasons I was the
commercial right here you got to plug
this thing into it right are you gonna
are you are you gonna cry when you leave
watch a commercial I showed the other
night with no sound on he just read it
and he cried backstage
I'm eating those oats you guys have a
pressure on them too they would have had
otherwise put pressure on them or hit on
them yes well it's like that forest go
music
[Music]
yeah
I'm gonna be getting mittens Oh kid cute
I got the chills oh you'll see I can't
Johnny talked through the best part and
it's still like I still got me shut up
Tiger Woods says I'm gonna be Jack
Nicklaus and then they wait to the
perfect and then you know that always
just gets me at the end but it's a
comeback story dude no oh yeah yes but I
think they had it locked and ready and
they were hoping that's the one yeah to
answer your question I don't think I
think that one small and airy put that
ball in the water he just was like [ __ ]
I'm done it's over and then he just
folded after that a couple of holes so
he was out of it but Brooke Skeptical
was like I can still get him I I'm no
I'm good enough I don't think he folded
I think he still chased him but still it
was incredible I mean I cried hmm my son
watched it with me he was he was he knew
he got he knows when I get emotional I'm
an emotional person so have you throw up
a lot to mind I mean yeah you're gonna
get everything with me your pink
concerts did you go I didn't go last
night I drove past it on the way home
from again you just circle around the
concert I don't go inside to get the
good ones I get the [ __ ] did you
really buy a juicer no I did it I had a
game you did most of each and I was
driving back through downtown I saw was
the pink concert so I pulled over and
got a scalp ticket no not by myself oh I
went with Simone
[Laughter]
I am thrilled I know you guys got to go
but I'm thrilled I'm so excited he's
gonna be the Burt
he's the odds-on favorite at the next
major it's next month let me ask you
this we were talking about this before
you got in by the way we're going to
cover all the odds on what's the odds
tomorrow live 2 p.m. Pacific on all
things comedy Facebook pages right Ian
was plug sorry go for it
the we were terminus really do you think
he has a chance at passing Jack
absolutely
see that's what I think I hear are you
ready I'll take you this Sam look at me
right now I guarantee you right now I
bet you right now he wins another major
this year as a bag of it bring it back
wait wait wait what cuz you'll have to
go forever no no I'm saying this year
he's gonna win another major within the
next 365 days no no I'm saying okay
thank you I'll take that what you're
saying I'll take the Masters to fine but
I was gonna say because he's won Sam
from now to the next one a 2002 at at
Bethpage Black he won the US Open there
that's the next major and then Pebble
Beach yo meet on G's wanted Pebble Beach
three three try like eight Wow including
a US Open which he shot like 21 under
wow that's the US Open so that's the
next two so I I mean next two he's
already won multiple times he's didn't
odds-on favorite eight to one then win
the next one
so who the odds-on favorite to win the
next one you're the favorite to win the
next couple right unless you blow up and
he no three nine is three he's well to
tie three to tie right but you're saying
in his career he's certain he'll get
well I mean we're a bag about your and
your so wait but you're saying between
now to the master master you're gonna
give me the Masters next year
of the season so three more majors the
the three left or you're gonna give me
the masters next year - how about this
just give me the option by the way if he
doesn't win one of the next three I can
pull another bed out of the thing -
double down for the Masters and you give
me the Masters that's interesting
because I think the Masters be the
hardest one from the win even though I
just want it you just wanted he's gonna
put that jacket on again dude you have
no idea what a dumb what a dumb thing to
win - Steve's always so William John
battles your neck if it's your balls you
gotta do a different one because that
one's already on the table if you're
never gonna do it what's it do the shock
collar what is it a shot
I already said idea originally on your
balls no you gotta do that I'm like I
have a vasectomy I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah the last thing you want is another
kid [ __ ] I got to do it Thursday I
can't do it tonight Thursday where are
you going
he's out of town for two weeks oh this
is no phone service or other device for
three days I've done no problem
pick it up that's a hard one man oh dear
you're [ __ ] done bro and we're doing
it three days three days without your
conspiracy theories Sam three days
without tinfoil
he's not gonna Ram and he's not gonna
win another one what if those three days
is when Julia Assange is like they were
like letting him out are we gonna talk
what's your take on the whole Julianne
sad thing it's pretty sad right look I I
don't think the guy's a hundred percent
a [ __ ] Patriot are the best person in
the world I think he's eight I think he
knew what he had I think he I think he
built a wonderful weapon and he kind of
was like what I'm gonna want to shoot it
a little okay but uh but but you can't
ask me my opinion of it I'd say and then
not give me my I can say your opinion is
interesting okay
well I'm saying he's got a powerful tool
at his disposal he built it he's curate
but he hasn't used it always for great
things but no one has ever used it for
you know saying like well I think he met
a hundred percent medaled and full and
and gave out information in the election
in 2016
okay he P pick the side and hedged his
bets that way so you think he's holding
on to Donald Trump stuff and he's not
releasing it oh I've no I'm sure he's
got stuff on everybody now he when you
release it here's what I want to know
and this is this case this is a
conspiracy theory that I want to ask you
about is it do you know that show lost
where it's like you have to put a number
in have you heard this one where he's
supposed to put a number in and a couple
days or whatever yeah and if he doesn't
all this information yeah yeah it's the
dead man swear that to me is very like
that's feasible to me I'm like that
makes sense to me I mean I could see
that happening I don't think that would
be a blanket thing forever I think what
he was hitting that's napalm what do you
think he released that he shouldn't have
in the election well here's a deal I
think that he had [ __ ] on everyone on
Trump too and he just released some [ __ ]
on on Hillary Clinton so he had said
he's tried to release stuff on Trump he
doesn't have it I can't imagine that he
doesn't have he goes after everybody
what why we know there's anything what
what do you think Trump has say what do
you wait even if they were in like
cahoots with each other
even people you know movies even though
we're partners yeah I have to have [ __ ]
on you in case the day you turn around
and sonís a hack I'm not saying Trump's
a good guy yeah Sonne has to hack them
take that stuff and give it to the how
of you know how has no one been able to
hack the 80 year old man how has no one
been able to hack the 80 year old man
you think you think all the all the
gaudy [ __ ] that guy's built you think he
built the most pristine server and and
and you know security system known to
man dude imagine why hasn't anybody
hacked him why because he they uh
there's a belief that they they did this
arrest to extract him so he could get to
the United States and testify this was
an embarrassment thing this was there
was to embarrass him I do
contacting him during the elections
oh-ho WikiLeaks reached out directly to
Donald Trump jr. during the election I
don't know that where it was lead where
I don't know that send me the
information are you gonna send me the
Atlantic tell me that while it was
everywhere I'm a can you know it's not
everywhere yes send it to me
send it to me I'm telling you Julian's
song doesn't do that's not what that
thing does there are 100 percent correct
they're batting a thousand when it comes
to releasing stories and I don't know
why people are more that's not that's
that the same thing it's releasing all
the stories you have what do you think
he's going to release what do you think
I don't know maybe a bunch of Cobras yup
snakes on a plane but what do you think
he had lion what do you think he has I
do I don't know tax returns that did he
whose tax returns has he released maybe
Trump's tax returns maybe it's a
Barclays account you know balances from
the 80s when apparently you know maybe
the the Russians were of laundering
money for Trump top I don't know like oh
maybe pastor Moore couldn't get his
hands on I don't know I what I don't
know
it's do don't laughing I love you to
death you're grasping here's my point
you asked me the original let's go back
do I think he's a good guy
I think what he's doing and most of what
he does is good to do Robby Dunn there's
nobody but I think the weapon he made to
do that he's also used for himself for
whatever reason to pick the guy paid
whatever it is whatever that is someone
would have to go to Julian Assange that
works with Trump and goes I have these
documents release things that's what
happened Seth rich gave them the
documents because he saw election fraud
that's where all this comes from
election fraud and then there you know
even deeper to stuff that she did
leaving that guy in Benghazi to die to
clean up loose she let him oh look what
this is in no way to sit here and
justify whatever whatever
Hilary said laughs was it okay with
demon saronite like did a sketch
demonizing Julian SOT I we are living in
the upside-down world right now it makes
no sense to me well I think it's eighty
eighty-five 1580 percentage-wise you so
you're saying my felt you're outraged
about my face I'm not nobody's perfect
no one's nobody is 100% pure okay I'm
not saying that I'm just telling you if
there's something release about Dom look
what he did to Ecuador he was using it
on the walls no he didn't you should
hide the pictures it's all a lie if he
did [ __ ] on the walls you got to clean
that up dude nobody man he was releasing
documents about all the [ __ ] Ecuador was
doing why he was saying that he duty did
he play soccer in the halls and break
[ __ ] I heard that too from who the news
okay the ones who told you there was
Russian collusion for two years Sam
listen to me yes there may or may not
have been Russian clue there was not
okay all right now I can tell you
exactly how one does that no collusion
not okay Carter page Stefan help her
were both [ __ ] plants it was like
thought but but no what no I think it
was a worthy look a worthy let's no look
no a waste of two years okay anyway yes
we want to knock yet came over the beam
it was a lie okay and that's been
punched on exploit sued they spot and
listen I hate Trump as much you hate
Trump they spied on him dude they
wiretapped as an elected president it is
worse than Watergate and that's just the
truth and nobody wants to talk about and
that's why everybody's freaking the [ __ ]
out right now cuz dude they got them
dead to rights and she's lied to
everybody the whole way she she didn't
think you want to read the report you
want to read the I know exactly what
happened I've been studying this for two
and over years okay two years I've been
studying this did you read a report and
I don't mean the reports called tinfoil
hat I've been studying and do I know
what I mean like okay but did you do you
art then even that even as a person
that's you didn't you would probably be
wanted
read his report another person who's
been studying here for two years
release write it it's just gonna make
her look even worse but will you read it
if he gets released I'll read it and and
I was assumed I would want to read
everything in it right
I mean what's it twenty five thousand
pages how many 358 pages over I'll read
it but dude I already know what went
down but I've been studying this okay
it's college students entrapment they
set it up all these all the show's over
but we'll talk after all all the
indictments are on old-fashioned [ __ ]
corruption it's not real I understand
that there's a lot of it